in this lesson we're going to talk about
how many fit inside okay i didn't know
what to call this lesson initially so i
just called it how many fit inside
there's always a problem on the ect
that's like this and
basically what it is it's a volume
problem and you're trying to figure out
how many
you know quantities of an item will fit
inside of something it might be brick
pavers it might be notepads in this
example we're talking about
encyclopedias so see if you can solve
this problem on your own pause the video
and we'll go through it together and
we'll show you how to approach it so you
want to pack encyclopedias into a box
that is two feet long two feet wide and
one foot tall right each encyclopedia is
eight inches by six inches by one inch
what is the maximum number of
encyclopedias you can fit in the box
okay
so what i would do is i would draw a
diagram basically you know here's your
box like this okay
and when you work with a box
oftentimes called a rectangular prism uh
the formula for the volume is just going
to be length times width times height
okay so it's the area of the base which
is you know length times width and then
times the height
so here's the thing we've got these
dimensions in feet and encyclopedias
dimensions and inches let's go ahead and
convert these
dimensions of the box into inches so 2
feet long is actually 2 times 12 inches
per foot that's 24 inches and this is
going to be 24 inches wide and 1 foot
tall is 12 inches tall so if we find the
volume of this
box it's going to just be 24
okay times 24
times 12.
so that gives us a volume of let's go to
our calculators here
times 24 times 12.
[Music]
cubic
inches okay now let's look at the volume
of one of the encyclopedias
okay it's eight inches by six inches by
one inch so we've got volume equals
eight times six times one so that's just
going to be 48
cubic inches so if we take the total
volume
okay divided by the volume for each
encyclopedia we should be able to find
out how many encyclopedias fit in this
box now
you're probably wondering well what
happens if they don't fit exactly
perfectly in this box and there's like a
you know just a little gap somewhere
here you know
left over well you know you can take a
look at some of the individual
encyclopedias you know see how many are
going to stack across the bottom and you
know make sure they fit perfectly inside
the box but from what i've noticed on
all these problems like this on the ect
is that
they actually work out perfect where
they fit in exactly with that volume so
you can double check that to see if
there's some kind of a you know trick
you know where it's maybe not going to
be completely full the box because of a
little gap but from what i found from
the previously released act
exams it works out perfect so if you
just take the volume of
each item and divide that by the total
you know divide that into the total
volume that's going to be the number
that you're looking for so let's just go
ahead and simplify this 6 912 divided by
48 gives us 144
encyclopedias and that's your answer so
again this is a typical problem on the
act it's basically just a volume problem
i call it how many fit inside
i'll see in the next lesson